à présent regarde
il est là
verrait là le roi milady le roi
son destin est écrit est une peut
échapper
au fisc tu m'as pour courgain 1 jour le
royaume n'appartiendra merci mon père
moi
[Applaudissements]
ou que le fumeur
vous mangerez nerveux vous sauverez
tient lieu de tête père et
mère je vous sauvera une heure la durée
[Musique]
pourquoi tant fuir vers cette contrée
infernale
pour retrouver ce qu'on m'a volé est-ce
que c'est
royaume
tu dois choisir entre l'amour pour les
tirs
et la haine pour des ennemis la force
brise les os des avants
[Applaudissements]
marc us brisera le resterai
nuit après nuit nous accomplirons la
vengeance dont j'ai fait le serment
r je vous faudrait percevoir
mr je vous serai maire je vous en vrai
via l'ingestion orale et